[Music]
most bosses don't really do any work so
today I've been asked for some reason to
figure out which one of these subjects
is the boss
take me through like a day or like a
week with the archive Department there's
a ton of videos being made here and then
we distribute it to our team and then
they have to like upload it to a cloud I
don't trust clouds I mean I I trust
drives I have to talk to my boss we have
a lot of meetings I don't think they're
like oh I need like Destiny needs to
approve this or see this it's more of
like sounds easier
who's your boss me you're the boss oh
well I mean I I'm within post-production
but yeah I'm a lead so what do you do on
a daily basis I do a lot of writes and
clearances reviews I confirm with our
media management team to make sure
I think it's Destiny
foreign